hey we all remember when Kellyanne
Conway talked about the Bowling Green
Massacre a terrorist attack that never
took place I'll remind you of that
before we go any further I bet it's
brand new information to people that
President Obama had a six-month ban on
the Iraqi refugee program after two
Iraqis came here to this country were
radicalized and there were the master
masterminds behind the bowling green
asset cart we might see what I know
that's a good thing yeah most people
don't know that because it didn't happen
then it was press secretary Sean Spicer
taking a turn referencing Atlanta
multiple times of course the only
terrorist attack in atlanta was the pipe
bomb during the olympics which was an
american-born white dude here Sean
Spicer referencing the Atlanta jihadist
attack with the inconvenience there any
humiliation no there's a hundred and
nine people that were slowed down over
325,000 foreign visitors that came in
but what what do we say to the family
that loses somebody of a terroristic to
whether it's Atlanta or San Bernardino
or the Boston bomber those people each
of whom had gone out to a country and
now Donald Trump is adding his name to
the list of Trump administration
officials who just make up terrorist
attacks that don't exist on Saturday
Trump did this bizarre sort of a post
election campaign rally I mean this was
a campaign rally it just that the
election is over Donald Trump talked
about an attack in Sweden on Friday
night yet another terrorist attack that
never happened you look at what's
happening in Germany you look at what's
happening last night in Sweden Sweden
who would believe this Sweden they took
in large numbers to havin problems like
they never thought possible what
happened the previous night in Sweden
nothing nothing happened the previous
night in Sweden the Swedish government
actually formally requested an
explanation from US Secretary of State
Rex Tillerson saying what on earth was
Donald Trump talking about Trump's
response sit down get the kids out of
the room Trump's answer was I mean this
is not the onion Pat okay Trump's
explanation was I heard about it on Fox
News check out the tweet that Donald
Trump sent out my statement
as to what's happening in Sweden was in
reference to a story that was broadcast
on fox news concerning immigrants in
Sweden the fox news segment from Friday
that Trump is referring to was talking
about integration and crime in Sweden
not any specific incidents so here's the
amazing thing I know I said you can't
write this stuff Pat not only is our
president getting his talking points
about global affairs from casually
watching Fox News he's not even paying
close enough attention to Fox News so
that he ends up with the wrong
impression of what his talking points
should be from Fox News that's the thing
I mean this is Fox News it's a media
outlet that goes in front of millions of
people so they want to be very clear and
straightforward on their words not much
nuance at all so if he's not able to
understand this how is he supposed to be
able to understand a national
intelligence briefing when there's
nuance and different opinion yeah I mean
it's no surprise that he wants it boiled
down into one page with a lot of maps
and graphs mostly pictures two to three
bullet points the reality is Sweden's
crime rate has been falling since 2005
there has been an influx of immigration
but the crime rate continues to decrease
former Swedish foreign minister Carl
Bildt said Sweden terror attack what has
he been smoking questions abound and the
Swedish embassy saying quote we look
forward to informing the US
administration about Swedish immigration
and integration policies during george w
bush's presidency it was bad enough that
Fox News was constantly downplaying all
of the disastrous actions of the Bush
administration but now we actually have
a president who himself is getting his
information from Fox News to begin with
let alone the fact that the president of
the US generally shouldn't be making
baseless claims about important topics
making them based on misunderstandings
of Fox News reports is particularly
concerning and we know that Trump is
just reacting to what's on Fox he
actually tweeted not long ago when Obama
commuted Chelsea Manning's prison
sentence the Fox News put out a story
calling Chelsea Manning and ungrateful
traitor and then a few days later Donald
Trump puts out a tweet referring to
ungrateful traitor Chelsea Manning so
basically it is a running commentary
from the
President of the United States based on
what happens on fox news this is very
very scary stuff folks